usually when I you know introduce the  counter so do you all know each other  but now Timmy you and I bit goose breed  because this is I think the first time  we've ever had this thing you guys you d  sit at one point date we live together a  serious item for a while yeah but I  remember ciarán hinds  myself we did this film Excalibur  together  yeah 1980s movie for all of us really  was that really so we were so green and  ignorant about filmmaking but I remember  being out of the said this was Ardmore  studios oh yeah  Dublin and how long had a break she was  filming but she was in costume and we  were there just visiting we hadn't  started work yet and the first idea of  the second lady said would you like to  meet the Helen mirror and said yeah I'd  love to  so she worked from like a hundred yards  away dressed and as Morgana le Fay and  Karen's my oldest friend and we both  went [ __ ] thank you Miss minty I was  [Music]  [Music]